[Music]  legendary race car driver Jimmy Johnson  says it is time to pull into the pits  for good he's going to retire from  full-time competition Johnson dominated  stock car racing in the early 2000s  winning seven NASCAR championships more  than anyone else but Richard Petty and  Dale Earnhardt two names you've likely  heard of two years ago though he left  NASCAR to start driving Indy cars and he  raced in his first Indianapolis 500 back  in May Johnson talked to us last year  about making that switch  IndyCar was always a dream for me  as a young kid but my path took me to  NASCAR so when Chip gave me the  opportunity to drive a car and drive an  indie car and feel it and under you know  understand what it was about it blew my  mind and quickly became a point of  interest for me Johnson's last race for  now anyway it's Saturday in Atlanta